Alex salmon of course hi Mr salmon we
appreciate you taking the time to do the
first broadcast interview with us here
at Sky News
um do you think that Nicholas sturgeon
should be suspended
well I actually think Hamza Yusuf has
set a perfectly defensible line you know
the presumption of innocence you don't
suspend people until the charged with
something and that hasn't happened as
yet his difficulty of course is that
wasn't the position adopted by Nicholas
Dodge or Peter model the chief executive
or husband when they were in power I
mean they used to suspend people to drop
your heart basically so you know hums
has difficulties not the position he's
taken which is a perfectly respectable
defensible I actually think it's the
right position his problem is it's been
compared with a whole Litany of other
people who feel quite rightly they've
been treated unfairly in comparison in
the in their cases some years ago
describe Nicholas sturgeon yesterday as
the best politician in Europe
what do you think
well that wouldn't be quite my
description but but nonetheless I mean
look there is a bigger issue than this I
mean humza really has to depart from the
previous administration he's got to have
a clear line of departure as the new
first Minister on what he's going to do
from what came before I mean the sap is
under a substantial Financial Cloud
that's not going to wait anytime soon
it's not about one individual it's it's
a systemic argument about what the SMP
has been doing and therefore homes are
really and he has to do this pretty
quickly has to set out a new agenda to
stamp his mark on being first Minister
as opposed to just being seen as
Nicholas Sergeant's candidate Nicholas
sturgeon's successor he really needs to
put his own mark on being first minister
okay what is your view of her um as a
politician you don't I'm guessing you're
saying she's not the best politician in
Europe what is she
what should some of the most substantial
communication skills that that politics
certainly in the UK have ever seen but
she left a very difficult policy Legacy
for her successor she left a rather
difficult position on Independence by
going to the Supreme Court for reasons
that no one's been able to Fathom and
and getting the idea of a Scottish run
referendum disallowed she's left a
difficult policy agenda in the Scots
Parliament full of you know pretty
absurd and silly policies like
self-identification closing fishing
areas bottle schemes you know abolishing
some trials by jury you know you're
never going to get a majority of Scots
behind such policies and my strong
advice to Hamza Yusuf is to sweep that
nonsense away concentrate on the key
issues of housing Education Health and
restore confidence in the Scottish
government's running of the Scottish
Parliament get back the reputation for
competence and efficiency and Common
Sense there used to be the the boo work
of why people respected the Scottish
Parliament so much
so just to clarify Mr salmon you're
saying that Scotland is further away
from Independence than ever because of
the actions of Nicola Sturgeon or some
of them
no I'm not I'm what I'm saying is we've
got to decouple the cause of
Independence which is Riding High in the
opinion polls the snow I mean a
polyester there showing at 52 percent a
pool last week because I'm already
showing at 53 these are sky high levels
for the support for Scottish
independence this has been the SMP
support has taken a dent because of the
difficulties that are surrounding that
party at the present moment so the
important thing is to tap into that
Independence support which is why I'm
suggesting there should be an alliance
between all the independence parties the
next year's general election in Scotland
there should be fielded one Independence
candidate in each constituency to
maximize the independence vote and we
should downplay the Party politics while
the SMP is under a cloud
but you talked about the Supreme Court
and the fact that as a result of the
ruling by the Supreme Court
um you know there can't be a new um
Indie ref and that was back in in
November and that was as a direct result
of the actions of Nicholas sturgeon
appealing to the Supreme Court
well it was uh Fool's Aaron to go to the
Supreme Court no question about that
therefore you have to find another way
of allowing the people of Scotland to
express their Democratic right of
self-determination which wasn't disputed
by his Supreme Court or by the UK
government we have to find a ballot box
method of allowing people in Scotland
the right to choose their own future my
suggestion would be to have General and
Scottish elections as that Ballot Box
opportunity hence the idea of a Scotland
United for Independence Coalition
comprising all of the independent
supporting parties the SMP which is a
dominant party Aleppo greens Scottish
Socialist Party let's have one candidate
each constituency on a Manifesto it says
we're looking for a popular mandate to
negotiate independence from Westminster
and incidentally there's a poll out
today which shows a majority of people
in Scotland back that position but
that's hence you describe it as a Fool's
errand that's hence my point that
because uh in your opinion Nicholas
sturgeon did do that fool's errand um
Scotland has found themselves in a more
challenging position when it comes to
any potential Independence
yes I should clarify if who's there is a
phrase I'm not suggesting Nicholas
dungeon is a fool clear that she's not a
fool she was a very capable politician
but going to the Supreme Court
was a was a was a I was almost a a shot
that uh alas gamble which had no
appreciable appreciable sign of any
possible success it was like the ACT
almost of desperation far far better if
Westminster chooses to block uh
Scotland's aspirations through a
referendum undemocratically
disgracefully and a few other things you
could add and then find another Ballot
Box opportunity in elections I mean even
the story government ain't going to
cancel elections anytime soon and
therefore that Ballot Box opportunity
should be taken next year's Westminster
election and the subsequent Scottish
elections after all before the Advent of
the Scottish Parliament that was the
route to Independence which was accepted
by every UK prime minister from Harold
Wilson owned it's time to reassert that
Ballot Box opportunity and allow the
people of Scotland to democratically
vote to determine their own future
I'm sure you're not suggesting that the
Supreme Court is on Democratic but I
wonder if I could ask you
um whether well that's weird I think I
think well I'm not suggesting it's
undemocratic but I'm suggesting is that
perhaps lady Hill's Supreme Court would
have come to a different decision to the
present Supreme Court which seems far
more conservatively inclined well we'll
never know
um did Nicholas sturgeon's arrest
surprise you
not immediately because you know there
are three signatories to the SMP
accounts bit of Morocco and BT Nicholas
sturgeon uh both Cohen and Peter Morrow
had been arrested therefore it would it
would seem that if the secretaries to
the council being arrested then you know
Nicola was next in line they were the
the key office Builders when this
financial problem was present and is now
being examined sure you would expect the
police to continue investigations
without fear or favor incidentally lots
of folk are asked about this and they
all say you mustn't comment on a a live
police investigation and then they
proceed to comment on it and the
exception I'm not going to comment on a
live police investigation just let the
police go on with it
um quick thought before I let you go are
there any circumstances where you would
consider rejoining the SNP
well I'm very content with the rule that
arapis playing in Scottish politics with
a growing political party we're
approaching 8 000 members that makes us
by membership now the third biggest
political party in Scotland far bigger
than 30 so the the liberal Democrats and
that we believe will be reflected at The
Ballot Box and of course if we approach
the next election as an independence
Coalition you'll find a way for the
independent supporting parties to work
together to maximize the opportunity in
each constituency to return an
independent supporting candidate
so is that a yes or a no to potentially
rejoining the SNP that is that is I'm
very content with Oliver but I'm very
content also to work in cooperation with
other people from other parties who
believe in the goal of Scottish
independence because that goal
transcends uh Party politics okay so you
wouldn't be you wouldn't join them again
but you might work with them
well that's a very fair summary of the
of the situation unless incidentally
gorgeous day in Edinburgh okay you
should be here it's absolutely fantastic
as it always is in Scotland I I know
that from a personal experience it's
always great to see you thanks for
joining us